[Music]
jet is the face of valorant she's always
been the poster girl for the game even
when some people didn't necessarily see
her true potential a lot of people
didn't use jet originally i remember it
was just like she didn't exist and
people just thought she was bad in the
higher level meta of this game i don't
think you will see jets ever
but once players mastered her jet became
unstoppable durka is left alone the
bladestorm pops he's up against an
operator and connecting every single
shot she's like one of the only agents
that can make aggressive plays and the
readjustment he might spot the cross he
decides to pull the trigger for
[Music]
i feel like it's the most entertaining
character to watch well he has to hold
though because if they rush back into
him and he if he doesn't find those
friends that could be painful
but when riot finally nerfed jet
somebody else took her crown
now she's back and ready to retake her
rightful spot at the top of the valerant
world he's going up and in the flash is
there and he's got your maniac this is
the story of balorant's most game
defining agent the story of jet what's
happening unbelievable do this
cool let's go
[Music]
back in 2014 riot games began
development on their newest title and
after spending nearly five years working
on it behind closed doors in october
2019 they gave the world a sneak peek
we're making new games and this one's
different so here it is project a is our
character-based tactical shooter it's
competitive it has precise gun play it's
set on a beautiful near future earth and
it has a lethal cast of characters each
with their own unique abilities riots
promised to provide a working anti-cheat
128 tick servers and little to no
peekers advantage kept the gaming world
on their toes but while everyone waited
to get their hands on project a all they
could do was compare the highly
anticipated tax shooter to cs go and
overwatch it was clear that project a's
gun play shared many similarities with
counter-strikes but the unique agent
abilities made it appealing to overwatch
and battle royale players as well and
that's exactly what riot was hoping for
for valor we wanted to find a nice mix
of both
compelling gun play while also injecting
really cool abilities that complement
one another one thing that
has helped a lot is we have a framework
for characters that we use to evaluate
what type of role that they would be
occupying within the game whether it's
you know creating lots of vision
blocking for their team over extended
periods of time
or somebody who favors taking gunfights
and being more of an entry fragger some
agents had smokes while others had
flashes grenades and molotovs so picking
a character often depended on the role
that you wanted to play within your team
but before the game even launched
players who were part of the initial
play test began gravitating towards one
particular duelist when i did the alpha
test the content creator test i was
under nda and stuff only character i
played was yet like at the very
beginning it's locking jet for me it was
movement stuff like playing cs like
everyone's on the same level even
playing field i said jet was like kind
of so crazy to me that like i could get
a free shot and dash away i could
updraft and take all these off angles
son wuhan is a former chef from south
korea who was forced to flee from her
job after she accidentally destroyed the
restaurant where she worked with her
wind-like superpowers eventually she was
recruited for the valorant protocol a
covert operation from alpha earth that
was created to protect the world from
dangerous situations involving radionite
sun wuhan became the group's tenth agent
and this is where she received her
nickname jet but jet isn't like the
other agents in the valor protocol you
see most members are mature and
experienced and always ready to get down
to business jet on the other hand is
childish arrogant and at times kind of
toxic yo we got problems
we you're the one that screwed up this
is fun who needs training dummies when
you have real dummies riot wanted
players to see jet's true personality so
finding the right voice actor was
crucial and they did just that it was
already weird to be quite honest it was
already weird like i already had like
white bleached hair my bangs were like
already like overgrown to the side had
my hair up in a bun
real lazy just went into the audition
and i'm like looking at this artwork and
it looks just like me that was already
like weird and then i just really liked
her story like where her
personality lies why she feels the way
that she does why she acts the way that
she does
yeah
do i sound like the enemy spotted spike
spotted
what it was just great that i was able
to kind of breathe life into this
character with my own interpretations
and and having that creative control
they wanted a little more of like
aggression so they were like you can
swear if you want to if you need to so i
was like great 30 seconds and i was like
there you are you little and
they're like great let's keep that in
if we can't let's keep that in so i i
really really wanted to to voice her
as soon as i did like the first audition
when the beta for the game finally
launched in april 2020 fans loved jet's
cheeky voice lines and everyone thought
she was fun to play but very few players
thought she was top tier and competitive
a lot of people didn't use jet
originally i remember
i think i was the
i brought a jet i remember in a beta
tournament and nobody else ran yet it
was just like she didn't exist and
people just thought she was bad and i
ran into the match just running
running jumping around hopping people
jumping at them with a shorty so
it was pretty strong i realized that as
the game fully launched and the pro
scene began to blossom more and more
players realized that jett was strong
her ability to play as an aggressive
entry fragger made her one of the game's
most desirable duelists but the spike is
being defused it's halfway done another
cloud burst goes down they're just going
to commit oh no he actually boosts out
of there this is insane
terry waiting up in the window
oh
that was sick but what made jet such a
strong pick was her ability to hold the
operator you see ballarant's operator is
slow and clunky in comparison to the orb
in cs go and due to the ability-based
nature of valorum jet was basically the
only agent players could reliably opt
with in the early days she could take
risky peaks on both attack and defense
and just dash away to safety regardless
of whether or not she actually managed
to get a kill in the right hands jet
looked unstoppable as valeran's
competitive scene continued to grow
worldwide it was pretty clear that jett
was already an essential pick on
basically every map all the top teams
had crack jet players who you typically
find at the top of every scoreboard and
for riot this was exactly what they
wanted you couldn't play or watch
ballarat without seeing her she had her
own merch and even skins in game so riot
didn't seem upset that she dominated the
meta in fact they even buffed her clown
burst and tailwind at one point before
players eventually began expressing
their concern suggesting that jet was
simply too strong some even thought that
she was so oppressive she was ruining
the game and once the first
international land came around some of
the world's best players showed everyone
just how strong jet really was yeah it's
been very hard to deny
this site take if your sentinels were so
little in the way of equipment we do
have the knives this time he's able to
nail duck a rather side he goes to sound
is annihilating everybody with the
ultimate suggest tucked in on the site
has reinforcements on the way but also
has the power of surprise durka is left
alone the blade storm pops he's up
against an operator oh and connecting
every single shot
it should be a post flaunt
unless anything can disrupt it i don't
think anything can
be one first time we get to really see a
fully fledged retake coming through
zephyr already gonna start this one out
for the spot play coming back on through
the penny way too quick just absolutely
eviscerates zephyr now gonna look for
more he keeps going penny is on a tear
right now he knows where the next
target's gonna be and he's unstoppable
in this penny with an incredible
playback through jeff's pick ray and
masters reykjavik 2021 was 80
higher than any other agent at the event
and at that point as difficult as it was
for riot to admit she was too good so
once players returned from iceland riot
finally listened to their player base
and nerf jet her dash could no longer
break cipher's tripwise and all of her
abilities including her ult went up in
cost it was definitely a step in the
right direction but once international
competition returned it was clear that
it wasn't enough in a beautiful push by
defoe here doug this is the blade storm
out this could literally separate
everything hundred these has worked out
so far this round
man they they just react so well but
definitely wins that with the bladestorm
goes up top not gonna spot anyone there
duffle still has that blade storm but he
doesn't have the spike he finds himself
in a 1v4 oh reset make that a 1v3
30 seconds left
reset okay make that a 1v2
[Music]
devo manages to pick up the spike as
well understands he goes there ethan's
going through there as well he goes
aggressive default good for four looking
to work the ace
with the blade storm he go he's gonna
util defoe does it my goodness a late
lurk by forward coming in through middle
as they claim the side and now look for
the plant but income cnet gonna make it
at least a little bit costly there's
absolutely no way that this player steps
up above he's challenged cned and he's
received exactly what you'd expect
another scene and just keeps on going
three kills with the off a tag into
another and this is getting scary with
just one down below trapped in russ
needs to make something happen while
pora is making the short play lurking
out trying to find space but cena picks
up four they've got nothing here so
forsaken potentially going to be in a
1v5
you laugh now he's seen it
never doubt forsaken this guy's coming
up with it that's two huge kills yay
potentially making a play for the orpy
he's one off the blade store but
straight away we'll finally open i don't
think it's even gonna matter here we'll
get it online at a long but central will
hit c
this retake has
so little impact in my mind at this
point
unless something like yay gets involved
he needed that to be clean i couldn't
quite find an intention pushes himself
oh my word three found
give him the fourth crashes will fall
for him give him the ace jess pick rate
somehow went up at masters berlin at 85
percent she was once again the highest
picked agent at the event players
returned home to more jet nerfs and
again they still were not enough likely
because riot refused to nerf the
strongest part of her kit her dash
whenever you watch like clips or
highlights it's usually jet knives or
like
a jet op or just like jet like getting
two kills and dashing out and getting
another kill barely do that with any
other agent you just dash away if you're
gonna die
actually that's basically the only
reason the character is good so in
typical riot fashion instead of just
nerfing just dash and calling it a day
they decided to release a new agent in
november 2021 one who will compete with
her as an opera much like jet chamber
has his own get out of jail free card in
the form of his rendezvous it allows him
to take a peek get a pick then tp out
before getting traded but nobody knew
whether or not chamber was good enough
to replace the face of the game since he
wasn't unlocked at champions 2021 jett
dominated the event with an 82 pick rate
now 2v2 for the retake decision strikers
they spot one challah takes him out
playstorms out
from buzz he pulls it off in an instant
the defuse is there but here goes tens
he's looking for information please step
oh there's the dash oh my god able to
get out of that cosmic divide comes
through a delayed exact onset besides oh
what a shot there from exxon and it is
beautiful early on here from fury
they have come to play
that is so sick dan yampi might have to
dash on top of the gen to open things up
and if he does that he'll be right in
front of vanity's face
set up here that util looks so good yeah
he has to do everything here and he will
he takes down vanity massive kill to
find that that was a must have from
yankee wrapping around finds another on
tree and there's very little left but
there's still leaf and
the frag on to link he's created an
opening on rafters for his team
as he looks for more
soulcat announces his position from a
main
leaflet oh my god this guy is
unstoppable
what else is he going to find here
dropping down oh my god
someone check this guy's computer leaf
is killing everybody and it won't stop
me it won't stop but her era was about
to come to an end
as the 2022 season got underway chambers
saw play across the pro scene but even
though he was labelled as a sentinel he
wasn't exactly playing that role instead
it was former jet players testing him
out as their team's dedicated opera and
once international competition got
underway it was pretty clear that jett
was no longer an essential pick not
having a jet in there is definitely a
little bit peculiar at least for what
has been played in the region and more
so actually coming up against ako which
okay sure fragging wise boaster hasn't
done much but it's more just that
utility just removing what they have
available
it's such a dirty angle and he's already
gone nothing they can do to trade it
although mystic was in spot but then
last hits the second shot as well yeah
this is something that you'll see from
jets in that position but
this guy
when it comes to first kills on the
attacking and defending sides chamber is
the king he can take an aggressive peak
and tp out to safety just like jek could
with her dash but some people argue that
rendezvous was even stronger because
rather than having to get kills in order
to use it again chamber just needed to
wait for it to come back off cooldown
and initially he could tp up to seven
times per round if it went the distance
so for the first time in ballarance
history jet riot's golden child was
falling out of the meta it didn't help
that they nerfed her dash even further
while chamber was beginning to take over
she wasn't dead by any means but more
and more players were realizing that
chamber was simply broken if someone on
your team wasn't playing him then you
were basically trolling chambers is the
best by far there's there's like there's
no contention for any other character
i honestly jud
yet compared to chamber for like hopping
is laughable
because you'll just die in your dash
whereas like chamber you just get out
for free some players were happy that
they no longer had to deal with jet
everyone had been complaining about her
for over a year but chamber was a
completely different animal and from a
spectator point of view he was nowhere
near as exciting to watch as a crack jet
player she's like one of the only agents
that can make aggressive plays and get
like get out safely so it allows like
streamers and professionals to play here
and make flashy plays so they can get
content i feel like it's the most
entertaining character to watch as well
as the most fun to play so
i think that's like super important to
the game because of that at masters
copenhagen jet saw her lowest pick rate
ever at an international event chamber
players continue to dominate in first
kills and the audience had gotten tired
of watching it copenhagen also had some
of the lowest viewership of any valorem
land to date and sure you could argue
that this was because some of the game's
most popular teams weren't present but a
lot of people were still hating on
chamber majority of it is just oh
chambers sit here with up and tp away
you know it's like that's pretty much it
and it's so strong but it's so simple
and one-dimensional that it does make
the game boring because you don't see
chamber updraft dashing into anywhere
after a flash no he's just you might
peak after flash yeah but anyone can do
that we all complain when jet was
dominating the meta and riot seemed
reluctant to nerf her she was the face
of the game so understandably they
didn't want to lose her but what we've
experienced this past year is far worse
chamber has ruined the game for many
players so with his recent nerfs we'll
just have to wait and see if it was
enough and until then everyone is hoping
that jack can return to her former glory
as the queen of valorant
because watching a good jet player fly
around and pick off enemies with her
daggers is what makes the game unique
and exciting to watch she's unlike any
other agent so a meta without jet just
doesn't feel right in many ways jet is
what makes valrant balorant this should
be a good catch tax one get the collat
sick
what's happening unbelievable do this
[Music]
you